alexis est heureuse de vous retrouver
dans la matinale d'ayrté france alors
pour vous faut-il interdire les sondages
à un an de la présidentielle
alors c'est une question qui se pose est
ce que alors c'est assez récent les
sondages d'abord avant de demander si
pour les intérieurs ou pas je pense pas
peut-être pas un an avance ça occupe
on va dire le monde politico médiatique
selon la loi française un sondage c'est
une enquête statistique qui vise à
donner une indication quantitative à une
date déterminée des opinions souhait
attitudes ou comportements d'une
population par l'intégration une par
l'interrogation pardon d'un échantillon
qui doit être représentatif de la
population qu'on fait elle concernait
donc c'est simplement un instantané de
ce que pensent x nombre de gens qui sont
censés représenter la population
française mais de l'avis de certains
sociologues comme pierre bourdieu par
exemple qu'il disait qu'il n'était rien
de plus inadéquates pour représenter
l'état de l'opinion qu'un pourcentage
et c'est vrai parce que qu'est ce qu'il
ya derrière et bien c'est des
abstractions statistiques une fiction
qu'on construit avec la vie finalement
de beaucoup de personnes qui vont
répondre à une question
orienté en fonction bien sûr de 2 qui va
donner l'ordre de faire le sondage
c'est un aussi un marché assez juteux le
sondage pas forcément le sondage
politique qui est récent le premier
sondage politique c'est l'ifop
l'institut français de l'opinion
publique qu'il le fait en 1938 sur
faut-il sauver dand sic
et puis qui le fait aussi au sortir de
la guerre en 1944 sur le rôle de la
résistance dans la libération et les
sondages construisent comme ce sont des
outils marketing construisent des biais
cognitifs en fait qui font que on va
aller souvent c'est l'effet flognman
vers l'avis dominant 1 par exemple si je
dis 85 % des français pensent que moi de
dire à bab et peut-être qu'il a raison
alors du coup il doit penser à un truc
bien et cette ff neiman il est important
il ya aussi l'effet qu'on appelle
underdog où on va créer des des chouchou
des sondages ou bien des des boucs
émissaires
à force de répéter par exemple que le
deuxième tour ce serait forcément
emmanuel macron et marine le pen
on en oublie le premier tour et c'est un
peu ça le rôle des sondages c'est vous
faire oublier finalement la réalité
d'une campagne présidentielle est là et
bien sûr le fond des programmes là on
est simplement à parler de qui est votre
chouchou
ouais alors des sondages qui se sont
trompés on en a vu beaucoup en ces
dernières années
qu'en pensez alors faut-il les interdire
vous n'avez pas répondu à la question
alors oui moi je peux personnellement je
pense que les laissons bas sont une
mauvaise chose dans une démocratie de
basse intensité surtout pour quelque
chose comme une élection présidentielle
et surtout un an avant l'échéance
sachant que nous n'avons pas tous les
candidats et le carré et nous sommes
loin d'avoir les programmes des
candidats
donc pourquoi faire ça si ce n'est créé
bien sûr l'opinion majoritaire à faire
croire que emmanuel macron sera déjà
candidat à sa succession et qu'il sera
forcément au second tour il ya là
forcément quelque chose de délicat et
puis il ya un lien incroyable entre les
instituts de sondage et le pouvoir
ipsos par exemple qui a été pendant plus
de vingt ans le sondeur officiel de
l'elysée jusqu'en 2007 les affaires des
sondages avec nicolas sarkozy à l'elysée
et puis plus récemment matignon qui a
donné plusieurs millions 4 millions à
l'ipsos 4 millions encore à l'ifop 1,8
million à bbb à 3 millions à opinionway
et 1 2 million harris interactive tout
ça ce sont des appels d'offres pour dire
combien aujourd'hui le politiques
scrutent le sondage et combien il fait
corps avec avec le sondeur et on en a vu
beaucoup c'est vrai des sondages sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire par le
gouvernement sur que penser de 2,6 ou
deux ça ça fait beaucoup ça fait
beaucoup trop c'est un marché comme je
le disais qui est dans millions d'euros
qui cherche qui se chiffre en milliards
d'euros pour ces entreprises qui sont
internationales et qui sont surtout dans
le marketing plus que dans la politique
et c'est là où finalement le sondage
politique me pose problème parce qu'il
n'a rien à voir avec le débat
démocratique avec finalement la
complexité que sont les débats que sont
les idées que sont les programmes et
pourtant ça ces débats notamment ce
dernier sondage du jdd que révèle-t-il
selon vous alors derniers sondages si on
doit en tirer plusieurs enseignements
c'est qu'il y à une abstention massive
et qu'il n'y aura pas forcément de
barrage républicain comme il ya eu
auparavant pour une candidate du
rassemblement national en l'occurrence
marine le pen on voit bien que
l'électorat est extrêmement volatil ça
dit aussi qu'à gauche
eh bien il faut c'est le temps des
grandes manoeuvres pour beaucoup
ne sachant pas sortir finalement un
candidat légitime ou un candidat unique
ce serait très compliqué et puis qu'à
droite
ce ne sera pas gagné face à marine le
pen là encore les électorats sont assez
assez complexe mais dans le cadre de la
construction d'une fiction on est bien
sûr encore une fois à un an de la
présidentielle tous les candidats ne
sont pas déclarés et on ne peut pas
savoir ce que vont décider justement ses
nombreux absents sioniste qui vont se
faire sans doute le scrutin de 2002
merci beaucoup alexis pour votre édito
ce matin alexis poulain dans la matinale
de france on vous retrouve comme tous
les lundis avec désirs à lundi prochain